今天想跟大家聊一個我覺得很有意思的案例，就是 Vienna Textile Lab，他們在做微生物染料。最讓我詫異的是，他們創辦人 Karin Fleck 其實有十年在石油和能源產業的經驗，後來卻轉去做紡織染料，這跨度真的蠻大的。
等等，石油能源跟紡織染料，這聽起來八竿子打不著啊。一般人會想，石油能源的利潤和規模通常更大吧？為什麼會想轉到一個聽起來可能沒那麼「大」的產業？而且還是在做一個可能大家沒聽過的微生物染料。
這就是有趣的地方。原文裡有提到，Karin Fleck 她是將她原本管理大型工業專案的經驗，轉移到解決時尚產業一個很嚴重的問題，就是傳統合成染料對環境和人體的傷害。所以她其實是看到了一個痛點。
解決痛點我是懂，但用微生物來做染料？這聽起來就出乎意料了。染料不都是化學合成的嗎？微生物能做出什麼顏色？穩定性夠嗎？成本會不會高得嚇人，導致廠商根本不想用？
你問的這些點都很實際。原文裡有提到，Vienna Textile Lab 正在將培養出來的微生物轉化成可用於織物的顏料。他們目標是提供一個「商業上可行、安全且永續」的替代方案。這表示他們應該已經考慮到成本和穩定性了。
商業上可行，這句口號每個新創都會說，但實際做起來又是另一回事。如果我是紡織廠老闆，我會很在意這東西染出來的顏色跟化學染料比，能不能達到一樣的鮮豔度？會不會一洗就掉色？這些都是實際影響產品品質的。
這點其實原文沒有直接說明顏色的鮮豔度，但它強調了這種生物基顏料在環境和社會影響方面的優勢。比如說，它解決了傳統染料高污染的問題。對現在很重視ESG和永續發展的品牌來說，這就是一個高價值產品。
嗯，環保牌確實是個賣點。那具體怎麼做到的？原文有講到是「培養微生物」，但微生物怎麼變成顏料？是直接把微生物塗上去嗎？還是從微生物身上萃取？這過程聽起來就很複雜，如果生產流程太長，成本怎麼壓得下來？
原文沒有詳細說明技術細節，但提到這是透過「生物技術」實現的。而且 Karin Fleck 從石油能源產業轉型，代表她可能具備管理複雜工業流程的能力，才能將這種新技術商業化。她有十年的相關經驗。
如果我是個創業者，看到這個案例，會覺得這種跨領域的門檻很高。要有生物科技的背景，又要懂紡織，還要能把兩種完全不同的知識結合起來，這不是一般人隨便能學的。感覺像個高科技創業。
我覺得可以學到的點，不見得是技術本身，而是這種「跨領域解決問題」的思維。Karin Fleck 看到傳統產業的痛點，然後從一個看似不相關的領域找到解方。這對中小企業主管來說，可以想想自己產業裡有沒有什麼問題，可以用其他產業的技術或觀念來解決。
你是說，就算我們不是做高科技，也可以學習他們這種「打破框架」的思考方式？但我還是覺得，像我們這種普通上班族，能把這個概念帶入工作或生活嗎？感覺有點遠。
其實我覺得可以。比如說，你工作上是不是有一些習慣性的流程，覺得很麻煩、很污染？像我們印文件，總覺得很浪費紙。有沒有可能，在現有資源下，去探索其他領域有沒有解決方案？或是找個「出乎意料」的合作對象。
聽起來像是說，不要只埋頭在自己的領域裡，多看看外面有沒有什麼新東西可以借鑒。但這需要花很多時間去研究吧？我們上班族時間就這麼多。
我覺得不一定要花大把時間研究，可以從觀察開始。比如多聽聽其他產業的案例，像我們現在這樣。Vienna Textile Lab 的成功，部分也來自於他們獲得了 Women TechEU 的資金支持，而且這個計畫是為了支持女性領導的深科技新創。這也提醒了我們，有時候外部資源的連結也很重要。
獲得外部資源支持確實是關鍵。這也說明了，就算技術再好，如果沒有資金和生態系的支援，也很難推動。他們不只開發新技術，還懂得利用資源。
嗯，這個案例讓我想到，有時候我們習慣的「常識」其實是阻礙我們創新的最大障礙。當一個解決方案出乎意料時，也許正是它最有潛力的時候。
這麼說好像也提醒了我們，在自己的工作中，是不是也有一些被我們視為理所當然的事情，其實可以換個角度去思考，看看有沒有更永續或更有效率的做法。